that's right right thank you where
everybody turned up tonight and welcome
to Stratford district councils a planner
nice committee my name is Andy Crump and
I will be joined tonight's meeting the
purpose of this meeting is to determine
the planning merit of the applications
before us hopefully everybody's got the
phones on silent or turned off because
there's nothing worse than somebody
speak and then the great escape team Jim
comes on and I've lost their flow
so again case the Barnes we're not on
about your landline this time I know
this occasion I think so yeah definitely
so again thank you so I'm just like to
introduce the top table
Karen Tate I'm the team leader plumbers
East in my role as an impartial of bozer
to the committee I can clarify any
planning issues that arise doing so I'm
bound by the code of Professional
Conduct of the Royal Town Planning
Institute planning committee members are
not bound by the case officers
recommendation or by oral advice Matthew
I'm planning officer job planning
officer thank you very much kendall and
council the st. thank you
okay definitely something it might be a
bonus for your cancer building yeah yeah
it's definitely gonna be one those
meetings like any just disclosure
members interest okay Safari chairman
I've received some information regarding
the first application I have looked at
it but I've come with chairman as board
member I will be speaking in the first
application and therefore stepping down
yeah thank you for that item number
three of the minutes of the meeting held
on the 16th of my I'm so you've all read
and peruse them and if you're happy to
approve them all thank you all right
before we start and two applications
tonight
there have been no updates for other
applications so rather than that and
waste winter papers 20 sheets of paper I
thought I just give you use verbal data
hopefully you're happy with that all
right now we'll move on to agenda item
number 4 which is application 18 / 0 1 1
8 3 very late bambi road pollutant
priors and it's variation of condition 2
of application reference 16 / 0 3 3 204
condition - alterations - elevation
including built parapet heights as shown
on during 3 1 3 /o 6.1 part
retrospective
so it's master your coin Thank You
Matthew Thank You chairman
so the the application site is in
pollutant Pryor's situated just off the
main road indicated by the black part in
the middle the screen there so the the
property is known as Leila and is
situated between the properties of the
gables and old road old Rose Cottage so
planning permission was granted in 2016
for a replacement dwelling and as you
can see from the site aerial imagery
there development has commenced in terms
of demolition and they've substantially
now completed the property so the the
application seeks a variation of
conditions in terms of the approved
plans from the original application so
I've got the approved drawings in front
of you there they're the ones that were
approved under application 1603 3 2 0
full and the next slide here shows the
current drawings before you tonight so
the the changes between the two includes
an increase to the parapet the heights
by about 30 to 40 centimeters and
they've added a 2 to 3 degree pitch to
the front sort of flat roof elements
just show you the two again so that was
the approved and that's currently before
you tonight so the the dwelling is
currently under construction and that's
the latest height photos as you can see
the parapet walls are situated either
side of the main entrance and then one
either side of the prophecy and again
the flat roof elements have now got the
slight pitch on them it's just another
photo so this is the view from the
driveway to the Gables looking towards
the dwelling and the parapet wall along
the side boundary there and this is a
view taken from the
eva's garden looking towards the parapet
so this is as built which is like say 30
to 40 centimeters taller than what was
approved so in summary I think the the
main issue before you tonight is whether
or not there's an impact in terms of
residential amenity on the neighboring
optimize the reason sound in the report
starting on page three and predominately
on pages 8 and 9 the applications
recommended for approval thank you Thank
You Matthew
well speaker which is cancer in green or
from pollutant prize Parish Council why
cancer green oh yeah I've been here
quite a few times so thank you three
minutes as usual and what you want thank
you thank you far away it's interesting
to note the reasons given in the
applicants planning statement for the
increase in height to that approved if
these go if these are genuine reasons
then why did they not submit an
application before construction rather
than as a result of a visit by planning
enforcement officer as well as the
parapets there appear to be a number of
discrepancies between the building as it
currently stands and the approved plan
if you look at photo 1 where where is
the door on the West elevation the
roofline also appears different to the
approved North elevation so is this
building accurate to the approved plans
we have our doubts we disagree with the
officers interpretation of policies cs5
CS and a s10 this whole application
depends on your view of harm and impact
in application of 1501 801 for the
planning officer acknowledged that the
scheme proposed at that time would cause
some harm to old Rose Cottage district
council submission to the planning
inspector stated overbearing impact on
the amenity of old Rose Cottage by
virtue of the size and mass
in close proximity to the boundary the
inspector agreed and dismissed the
appeal in his report for the approved
application the officer implied that
because the height of the single-story
would be 3 meters he said I acknowledge
that there will be some minor harm but
not to be sufficient to warrant the
refusal of planning permission bear in
mind that the plans have been amended
after negotiation instigated by the
owner of old Rose Cottage without this
Agreement the Parish Council would have
maintained its objection so the
application would have been hurt by this
committee rather than just a delegated
report however the construction has not
followed the agreed and approved plans
so the concessions made being ignored
again the planning officer admits there
would be some additional impact how much
impact does it need to make before it
becomes excessive he might not think it
is detrimental through loss of light but
the solid walls are clearly visible from
the patio of old Rose Cottage
and therefore impacts the visual amenity
that policy cs5 looks to maintain policy
cs20 states that a replacement dwelling
should not be visually intrusive and
significantly larger than the dwelling
replaces the additional height makes
this building even more intrusive and
impacts the residential amenity evolved
Rose Cottage so should be refused
against policy CS 5 CS 20 and older
settings
we feel that any building should match
the approved plans in all areas so urge
you to refuse this application and the
council take action to ensure works are
in to take and to make the building
match the approved plans
nothing will do that fer the officer
because officers got B I thought it we
want Jim and yet I think it's probably
probably saying that I think has the
green nose got some idea but but they
were just that the speaker didn't
mention the difference in the heightened
yeah I think we go back to the the
officer I think it was 30 to 40
centimeters to to the ease but again
will seek proper clarification in a
minute any any other questions
No thank you catch the green all you've
got got a flock is unless we move on to
our next speaker which isn't just a
Peter bottom they can do either either
those whichever is most comfortable
no it's not a problem at all take your
time got plenty a time doesn't get dark
till about quarter past half past 10:00
tonight so we're okay right
right far away you've got three minutes
and would you like a warning shot at
about 30 seconds to go yes thank you
yeah thank you so yeah feel free to stop
when you're ready all right my
involvement with the enforcement officer
stems from an excessively high wall to a
single story bedroom block erected on my
western boundary directly opposite my
patio area which is my main amenity
there was nothing there either to the
additional wall height has to be seen in
the context of my long-established patio
being 1.7 meters below ground level of
lay late and the same applies to the
floor of my house there's then three
point three nine meters of structure to
add to that gives the language of the
core strategy in the wall is not
sensitive to its sight and surroundings
and causes me considerable harm as the
planning inspector had anticipated in
his report on an earlier failed appeal
dated the 7th of September 201 six my
son and I met mister mrs. carala on the
6th and 26th of November to about 2016
and agreed some changes to the plans and
confirmed the arrangements with
handshakes or R and this included wall
height of 3 meters for the bedroom block
any changes made after our meeting on
26th of November and not not foot
notified to me and I'm not acceptable
the height should be reduced to the
original 3 meters
as a matter of record canceled a penny
on O'Donnell visited my house on the
19th of June 2018 and seemed quite
perturbed by what she found there
brilliant thank you very much within
Thomas Marceau doing well tonight I'm
just for clarity mr. Barnell come on
they sure it's Rose Cottage you live in
yeah I thought it was her just making
sure
any questions mr. Barra no I'm saying
must have been so so self-explanatory in
the pictures were sent a thousand words
very well thank you very much so our
next speaker is mr. James Cohen mr.
Cohen you've got six minutes when you're
ready and if you're you are in full flow
and that will give you a warning shot
after shot with 30 seconds to go thank
you thank you for letting me speak to
see me it seems there's been a number of
mentions back to inspectors comments on
a previously and ultimately refused
planning scheme I do ask that you please
disregard these comments as they're
completely irrelevant and refer to a
different design the refused game was
for a 2-story dwelling not the mostly
single storey building we have now and
when impacts a neighboring amenity was
being discussed we were talking about
fart all the wall Heights than the 339
centimeters we're talking about now and
consider devoted to the boundary as well
I believe if you have reviewed the
original and granted application
including the amendments you will know
that whenever any changes to the parapet
wall Heights nor were there ever any nor
were they ever mentioned in any
consultations or comments to my mind
they were not contentious at all which
is why I firmly believe how do we have
these parapet wall was drawn at the
correct height originally the
application would have been granted in
exactly the same way that it was the
issue has simply come from not
understanding the demands of the
insulated
products we were using for the flat roof
the specific issues were a the panel's
finally chosen with slightly thicker
than first thought because we have
decided on a better insulated product
for environmental reasons be the
supplier amended their initial
requirements and informed us that we
needed a ventilation brought forward
above their flat roofing panels
something we'd not considered see they
could not be laid flat I needed at least
two degrees fall to prevent condensation
and moisture build-up something else we
didn't know the product unfortunately
and the beam that was then required to
support them had to be large in the
first thought these four reasons alone
meant the four parapet highest lifted
during construction design and the net
effect was the thirty nine centimeters
increase you see it now
he's only with hindsight I've come to
learn that this happened I did read a
guide on committee developments for
single story building extensions when a
planning application is not required
which allows heights of up to three
meters when within two meters of a
boundary fence and four metres went
further than two meters away we have one
point seven five meters away from the
boundary of old Rose Cottage and between
one point seven at one point two away
from the boundary of the gables whilst
the permitted development for extensions
is clearly not clickable in this case I
do believe it goes some way to show how
acceptable a height of 339 centimeters
is in planning terms I also know that
the neighbor in the gables who is
actually closest to this wall has
decided to make no objections and the
minor change in high during our planning
and application we met with the art
owner of all gross cottage that comes to
a mutual agreement on what both parties
would be happy to support as a result of
this meeting we timber clad a large
portion of the wall facing the old Rose
Cottage
and quite a large increase in cost
surely for this neighbors benefit which
was made at their request at the same
time there was an amendment made to the
length of one of these walls in which we
extended it want me to further forward
on the old Rose Cottage side which this
neighbor actually suggested and
supported this amendment to the
submitted plans to increase the size the
wall was not met with any
dissatisfaction in fact the only
neighbor that complained about this
issue
then wrote in support of the application
and the amendment to enlarge the water
laws the property
we're not developers we're a family from
Oxford who decided to build our own home
in that local area you moved in with
parents to do it and here we are five
years later still living with them now
and also with our two young children I
do sincerely hope we can put this issue
to bed this evening because we want to
focus on moving in in the next couple of
months as I've already said I'm 100%
convinced there would have been no
difference in opinions or decisions with
this application had it been drawn at
the correct height of 3 point 4 meters
from the start thank you thank you very
much so thank you good evening um can
you just advise when you were aware that
the height of of the wall was going to
exceed the original 3 3 meters and what
you actually after treatments Misha I
would call from the or the email
notification for the enforcement officer
was done long as it was right ok so then
which point we measured everything can
we go back to the photograph from Rose
Cottage what's the material side of your
building its render
I've got one question mr. Cohen you
talked about the insulated panels
causing the problems I think the
supplier meant the penalty can't be
right flat from the two to three degree
slope etc and the beam being bigger
thicker a higher need to support them
when did you became become aware of that
those things will have gone on
throughout the design stage and unhappy
with the architects in not letting me
know that there was any changes to
designs like these are things that went
on past me I became aware that these
things that happened at the Enforcement
Officers notification in terms of the
construction design I made the decision
on the thicker panels my naivety I
didn't consider came to note lifted the
house at that point okay thank you any
other question is the bond you may and
then can I say officer as well playing
officer is three point three to three
point four meters or we've measured that
I think he's three hundred thirty nine
centimeters
he has bill
there's no further questions mr. Cohen
could you just turn the mic off please
thank you right now on any points of
clarification for the officers which is
that oh sorry I guess they're done on us
you were hiding there in the corner and
we'll move once again so don't know
cancer bombs hidden I've been told off
that was just the okay no problem you've
got five minutes Phil whenever you're
ready we're looking chair and committee
I think this is a difficult situation
and I'm relieved that I don't have to
vote on this I strongly believe that
this is sight sensitive and the
committee would benefit from a site
visit there are three main areas to
consider do you believe the applicants
are fully respected the guidance the
core strategy does the increase in
height actually have an overbearing
impact on the old Rose Cottage which is
why I recommend a site visit for you to
determine because they are really
unusual level differences between the
two plots and buildings which is
something that was picked up by the
inspector who did refuse the previous
application and whether you take note of
his report or not he did draw attention
to the fact that the difference between
the levels in the plots was of concern
so it's worth bearing that in mind
and finally what president is setting if
you allow applicants to once permission
is granted tweak away really without any
concerns for the neighboring occupants
you know we have a strict guidance from
the core strategy and is it acceptable
that the guidance is ignored in any
fashion without discussion in the hope
they're simply not noticed or we can get
away with it whether the applicant was
blameless or not that's thus he's in
charge of his team that's in charge of
the build we look to CS 9 and that says
to ensure high quality of design the
development will be sensitive our
sensitivity is a key word here because
sensitivity me to attack for careful
thoughtful and diplomat
and delicate in your negotiations and I
would suggest that this situation is
anything but simple sense ative with
regards to how mr. Brahma has been has
been treated it also recommends that you
make the best use of on-site assets as
well as public views and vistas and not
harm existing ones and cs9 goes on to
suggest that the involvement of local
residents and communities in the design
of development which affects their
locality is critical to achieving good
design
well the way in which mr. Byrom's good
faith in a handshake and a gentleman's
agreement regarding the adaptations he
agreed to indicate that his
contributions and involvement meant
nothing yet he looks out on the
consequences of his good faith in human
decency sadly on a daily basis his patio
again as was noted by the inspector is
his main private amenity space as he
recovers from his stroke his patio and
garden should be psyched for relaxation
for him and not a constant source of
irritation and stress looking at cs5
landscape and visual impacts the
proposals include an assessment of the
likely visual impacts on the site's
immediate and wider settings my question
hopefully this has been assessed with
the impact on the patio of old Rose
Cottage ethically from the photos the
scale of development should also
according to Siesta ID be appropriate to
its immediate surroundings and location
the extent of the development would not
have an unnecessarily harmful impact on
the surrounding landscape and setting of
the development simply because the
neighbors on the other side haven't
complained doesn't mean it hasn't had an
impact on on how their house is situated
now then we look to a s 10 and it states
that developments must minimize the
impact upon occupiers and users of
existing properties in the area and
sadly the lake looks like the wrong
house on the wrong plot now it also
advises us that replacement dwellings
subject to its scale and design should
not cause an appropriate harm to the
character the area or neighboring
properties and I would argue that this
now does they're talking about saying
it's 30 so many centimetres it's the
difference in the levels of the plots
that makes it quite a you know obtrusive
now to order his cottage
cs20 advises that a replacement dwelling
will be well sited in relation to
existing site and buildings and not
visually obtrusive
I also look at the photos or
significantly larger than the building
it replaces and Linnet is overbearing in
relation to the old Rose Cottage the
planning aspect of M refusing the
previous application advised that the
increase in height whilst relatively
more
list would be accentuated the occupiers
of old Rose Cottage and its patio area
by significantly higher ground level on
which the proposed building would be set
so again it's worth visiting the site
that he concluded that the development
would cause material harm to the living
conditions of the occupants of old Rose
Cottage and it would contrary to the
objectives of paragraph 17 at the NPP F
where he seeks to ensure high quality
design and protect the immunity of
adjoining occupiers if we're being asked
to disregard the inspectors report as
the applicant has done I would ask you
to disregard the facts and figures he
provided because he admitted that the
distance but
relevant to actually their their
application authorities below didn't
explode two meters and suddenly the
applicant doesn't know how the committee
would have voted if the parapet walls
have been drawn to the right height he
doesn't have a crystal ball so I would
urge you to go against the officers
recommendations on this Thank You
councillor Donnell thank you for that I
haven't been to the site obviously
looked on the patio but the there is
also part of the house behind the
parapet wall which from the photographs
looks quite a bit higher can you confirm
having been to the site is it higher the
library that made some concern about
because it's a west-facing it's
obviously concerned with the Sun setting
in the West I just want to get a bit of
a feel that if if the it might be for
the officers to - but there is a higher
part than the actual wall sitting behind
the wall so the Sun would hit that first
before it hit the wall could you just
give me some comments on that please
well definitely that the area behind the
is higher and when you go to the end of
the garden at alders cottage it's really
quite intrusive and as you drive up and
Park at Rose Cottage it's the first
thing you actually notice so it is the
parapet wall has obviously come further
than I think the residents were
expecting and is higher
and because it's higher as well another
thing to bear in mind is that there is a
window that can look into the patio so
it's just I know it seems like a tiny
amount of a difference in a wall height
but given the change in the levels of
the plots it makes a big difference and
it's a lot when you're when you're
standing in the garden it looks a lot
larger than that you know it's it's it's
a it's a modern contemporary design
it's obviously taking a lot of thought
but unfortunately this rise in the
heights is does have a big impact I'm
not sure that's prolly a question for GM
residents I don't think I can answer
that they're councilor fielding yeah I
think it was to do the ridge height
rather than actually all color of the
veranda yeah I don't think the color was
mentioned in the it was to do with the
ridge hide from sorry excuse me both the
products on the objector so I don't
think the the color of the the render
was particularly concerned but again we
can ask the officer when we get two
points of clarification wasn't building
it was just that it is a true serve but
I can see the lines we're going along
there yep okay so bonds did you indicate
earlier oh you just waving to me
I think it would be really useful
counterbalance yes right I think further
questions thank you can't slow down
we'll go to points for clarification
okay so Perry Thank You chair I wonder
whether the Matthews you can just give
some indication on the height of the
wall that looks as though the some form
of overflow or some sort of pipe I would
just like to have a bit of a feel where
the difference in height would be on on
the photograph and would it be a I'm
assuming because 39 or whatever it is 39
centimeters with that feature above that
pipe yeah I like thinking old can't
think in centimeter thank you yeah I
can't say for definite where it falls on
that wall but it would be roughly where
that feet that sort of would be I'll go
back to the side elevations there so you
can see where the existing pipe hopper
is on the the down pipe of that
elevation that was what was approved and
that's what's now there so he's here
so obviously obviously the plans aren't
a hundred cents scale but it the the new
hopper is slightly below where the
height increase has come from so it'd be
roughly where that down pipe is
just above the hedge line yeah
Casa Barnes thank you yeah I think it's
very difficult to measure a hundred cent
from the plans due to the thickness of
the lines on the plans but it is about
30 to 40 centimetres possibly closer to
the 40 centimeter mark mr. Perry did you
want to come back yes I'd just like some
clarification on the higher hedge and
whose boundary that is in is that part
of the boundary of the lay lets or is it
part of Rose Cottage and how high is
that hedge and I'm just trying to think
about comparisons from the highest part
of the hedge because it looks similar to
but it could just be from where the
photograph has taken it looks a similar
height but it would be helpful to just
to have some indication as to how high
that hedges thank you again I don't how
many exact measurements of the hedge
itself I have got some photos of further
into the garden so the hedge is on old
ray Scottish side so that there is a bit
of level change across the site as well
so that this bit allowance slightly
higher than the patio area so the garden
is set to the left-hand side of that
photo looking sort of back towards the
property in the road
I'd like to know what time of day the
photograph was taken I can't
178 on that one I'm afraid sorry I want
to see I can't I wouldn't be able to say
from memory that that's the orientation
of the site in terms of the gardens are
completely south-facing so in terms of
light impacts this will that only have
an impact sort of later in the afternoon
if it's all due to when the Sun comes
around yeah that's well I haven't got a
full block plan of the entire site but
this is the this is the floor plan that
shows the neighboring properties just
coming into the side of the images there
that's that only shows really the gables
it doesn't really show the the
neighboring property of the old Rose
Cottage
but the pathway would be to the top
right-hand side of the screen I'm just
concerned about the Reverend relevant so
this really counts the field him because
we're on about but Ron about the height
aren't we and this is the backbone
jury's is I don't think that really
impacts on the back boundary
that one current check can I also to the
to the map that's sitting on their
agenda page which shows you the position
in relation to both the gables and
cottage I would remind committee that
planning permission was granted for the
for the development in this location we
are dealing specifically with
alterations in terms of the parapet wall
so discussions obviously in relation to
the siting of the of the development now
we now past that point that that the
development has planning permission for
the house in this position thank you
Karen that's very helpful
I'll give you I'll give you a little
break a minute I'll ask must may sir
about the president's
Road on all referred to shall we get
president I'm sorry if we get
retrospective applications all the time
it doesn't set a precedent in my view
although I'm not saying that an
applicant may use it against the council
when making the decision but thank you
and I've got to cook the points for
Matthew and again Ken so Donna touched
on several points yes five is ten yes
twenty basically regarded overbearing
not very intrusive replacement building
minimize it such that did you pick up
any of those yeah I think they're all
taken to into account in my in my report
a lot of those policies of relating to
the the replacement dwelling and like
Karen says the principle of development
here has been established so really when
we were assessing this application we
need to be considering whether or not
the increase in parapet Heights would
lead to any to any con sort of conflict
for those policies I don't think they do
thank you very much not any further
questions we move on to the debate case
the time has started so I think I will I
think first and foremost I do understand
and sympathize with the occupier of Rose
Cottage but balancing that against I
feel the owner this is not something
that was done purposely and I and I
think where I'm coming from
there is a high hedge there is a high
hedge that
well it's certainly higher than the
existing hedge whilst there is some harm
I do not see the harm as being
substantial by an extra thirty nine
centimeters and I think if it if it went
to appeal it would it would be allowed
anyway and therefore whilst I have every
sympathy with the occupiers at Rose
Cottage I shall be going with the
officers recommendation for grant bonds
just appear that it's only marginally
wrong compared with the actual full
height and like the last week I don't
think we can a winner an appeal I have
sympathy for them look at but I was I
would put like a condition if we've I do
approve it that the render is a if you
like a look look or a different color
it's very stark take a turn it down
would make a big difference
officers recommendation is is that a
proposal can we come back on this if we
can go back to the photographs as you'll
see the the building is a white render
across the majority of it if you're
seeking to introduce a new color into
into one wall only obviously that woman
has a potential for impacting on the
rest of the building in terms of you
have a different color to one wall as
opposed to the rest of the building the
other point that I'd make is that white
is this maybe off-white is the color
that is usually used to give the maximum
amount of reflection back back in
daylight so must appreciate the color
may seem stark it does actually
generally it will improve the amount of
light and the feeling of lightness when
viewed from particular and view from the
patio I'm not quite sure what what
alternative colors you would use that
were that could didn't also need to be
very light potentially reduce the
effective nature of the light that's it
and also there's the impact on the
actual design that I have the actual
color for the rest of the building
sure yes rather better than I do
tents the barn looking at from where we
are the people in the house we have
houses and we've just had an application
with the offices and gone through door
we've got some Cotswolds render some
iron stone and render and it looks
substantially better than white and I
think that it would make very little
difference to the house if this
particular siting from the neighbors was
in an iron stone or a Cotswolds type
color render to make it applicable to
the area that we are now looking mr.
Perry please go back to conspiring chair
um I think the the weather conditions of
the day need to be taken into
consideration because if it because it's
a bright sunny day and blue sky the
white clearly stands out but if the day
was a gray cloudy day that white
wouldn't look as bright and standing out
and and my personal view is I don't
think it makes any difference on the
impact on the patio and I think if you
were to take the same picture on a on a
very on a typical English summer day
which is unread it's very rare to be
bright blue I don't believe that white
wall would look quite so bright
everything in the picture looks bright
because it's a sunny day
I'm sorry mr. Nash's just reminded me
that we need to make sure that our
conditions are not unreasonable so if we
do agree with this condition the
opponent so the applicant could actually
potentially appeal against them
unreasonable conditions I think that's
another point we need to take into
consideration so can we just have a
reminder of your proposal then hence the
bronze base so we have a reminder place
of your proposal the problem is long so
we're not in a course although I don't
see why there isn't any reason that the
man will be sitting out on the sunny
days not when it's raining and as far as
I'm concerned it's something that I
wanted to put forward and then quite
happy to catch the brain condition
recommendations without a condition okay
I've been advised that we need to go
because the bonds is have we've got a
seconder for that we'll go to the next
proposal which is kind of the brains and
have we got a seconder for that it's
okay as the Perry thank you so we'll go
to the vote um that's the brains
proposal all those in favor chairman
any abstentions that's counted yeah
counsel was asked to grant application
don't wait for 18 / 0 1 1 8 3 it's not
early
thank you
move on to the next item on the agenda
cancer field in cancer Barnes with me
ready good good thank you
which is 18 / 0 0 4 2 5 f you out
Sheldon Bosley hub Pizza Y Avenue ships
in Monstar a retinue single-storey much
of the building for uses nursery and the
presenting officer on this is Joe Brooke
Thank You chair the application
reference 18 / 0 45 full is situated on
northwestern edge on us of ships and on
stellar
the application site marked I can read
lies to the south eastern edge of an
area past and in last year's tennis
courts for the Sheldon Bosley community
hook which itself is located on the
western edge of the built-up area
boundary of Shipton on style this is now
a shot of the pros application with a
side marker in red the site is accessed
from pit way Avenue which is pit way
Avenue just here onto a private road
onto the shoulder and Bosley hug the
seldom ballsy hub which is this large
building you see before you is situated
to the north side and as a social
enterprise community building with a
parking area quaint to 1760 square
meters so what's the application site is
as ships and on style of bowls green
bulbs green and to the east is a large
open playing field which belongs to the
ships on style high school to south is
pit way Avenue which saw its disguised
as access and the residential dwellings
which are semi detached two-story tiling
to construct a red brick but not to a
slave reef and I will show you photos
beyond that beyond the ship then Bosley
hub is an area recreation which is
located just there
as indicated by the witness site plan
the proposal is for the stationery of a
temporary modular building which come in
condition for its temper used to be used
as a Children's Day Nursery D one use
non-residential institutions
the hub is also as assessed as falling
within the use Class D one and
Children's Day Nursery offer also falls
in the same use class the area to be
used comprises of a part of a redundant
tennis court and his currently used for
over spilled car parking for the hub the
site will remain part of the home the
modular building will equate to a
hundred and forty-four square meters
were a set length of 18 meters by 8
meters what we do with we have an oval
refight of 3.2 meters as witnessed by
the elevation drawings the modular
building with a standard rectangular
shape with a flat roof these are the
views of the two nearest dwelling is
approximately 27 meters way up it way
Avenue additionally this is the access
point going into the Sheldon Bosley hub
there is a soft slope when coming into
the Bosley hub this is a view taken from
just beyond the recreational ground this
is where the application is proposed to
be sited as you see as an area of hard
standing and at the moment he's used as
car park in the caravan indicates this
is the same photo taken just often Green
sorry I'll go back taken just off the
green that's where the application is
proposed to be sited it's well screened
on the back with mature hydro where the
high school was situated
this is the Sheldon Bosley hub and the
associated hassed and instead the area
in front of his two-car parking and it's
roughly 2.5 meters to three stories high
constructed out of brick with Roy white
metal frame windows and doors this is
the Bowles green to the west of the
application
this is a recreational field behind the
Sheldon Bosley hub when looking down you
see where the indicator in the top
left-hand corner and these are examples
that temporary models are building which
is proposed to be instilled the material
is prosed
our prefabricated modular building we're
still frame could great as seen on the
screen detail I approached model
building will look if the application is
approved the officers recommendation is
for approval thank you thank you thank
you mr. Cooper got three minutes would
you like a warning shot after no I did
it should be okay that's what I like to
hear so far away when you're ready thank
you Thank You chair good evening to you
all
considering this application has proved
to be difficult for ships and Town
Council although we welcome the concept
of additional nursery capacity locally
this must be balanced with the
requirement for site safety particularly
relevant where vulnerable children are
involved we've reviewed the updated
information provided together with the
responses from highways and
environmental health
we intend to concentrate on the
remaining primary area of concern
security for the record we agree with
the comment made by the Environmental
Health Officer that it would be better
if the building were to be moved towards
the rear of the site further away from
the vehicle entrance to the hub the
space is there so why not use it all the
regulatory requirements including
security guidelines for new nursery must
be completed so far no evidence of this
has been produced according to the
applicant the nursery has to offer and I
quote free flow where children have the
choice to be indoor or outdoor end of
quote
it's intended to have an external play
area at the front of the building this
must be inside a secure physical barrier
currently there are no plans to provide
this it only takes a momentary lapse of
concentration and a child could easily
stray into harm's way
children of the toddler age don't know
or understand fear they're inquisitive
and they're attracted to something new
they will take advantage of
opportunities all of us who are parents
understand this
do you remember abigail ray she was the
little two-year-old girl who on the 28th
of November 2002 slipped away unnoticed
from the ready teddy go nursery in lower
brailles she was found one hour later
having drowned in a nearby pond how did
this happen
agate hadn't been bolted let me repeat
this application proposes no secure
physical barrier at all around the
external play area we owe it to all the
interested parties to ensure that any
nursery provision puts the welfare of
the children above all other
considerations this application in its
present form isn't acceptable to us if
the security concerns can be
satisfactorily addressed in any new
application we will be pleased to
reconsider our position until then we
ask that consent for this proposal be
refused this is this is our sole primary
reason so you don't have any planning
reasons for objection oh the the issues
that other came up were actually large
in the address to some extent by the
responses on the side yes okay so you
don't have any planning reasons to
object to this application no thank you
good evening have the applicants liaised
with you throughout the application no
okay
but apart from security you have no
other concerns that's the whole town
council has a concern because rails
being very close to us it's still fresh
in the mind security you have no other
concern security you may be mindful to
put a condition on
hence the bonds its hub is in constant
use but primarily the drive part of the
path to the left hand side is primarily
used obviously so it's one of the same
if the officer brings it back up onto
the screen it's a rally event yes yes I
would walk that because I live close by
but it is well used by vehicles
generally and following on from that
when there's an anomaly is it what time
is the social club open is it money used
at evenings and weekends
that's correct but you do get instance
like using the bowls club they may have
events during the day thank you
now our next speaker which is Miss this
is Katie sighs the apologies if I've
missed how about it thank you
you've got three minutes okay can you
put the speaker on yeah and and we'll
give you a shout with 30 seconds to go
so just take your time when you're ready
compose yourself okay far away okay so
when we originally put the plans in the
idea is it's going to be run between
three of us we actually my mom has 25
years plus experience she's a child
minder so she's already familiar with
Ofsted and covers regulations my sister
is also nanny of nine years so we are
you know we would obviously comply with
the offset regulations and the idea of
the building is a temporary building and
so we get established and we found
grounds that we were able to buy
hopefully purchase and move to my
apologies on the plans we obviously
haven't marked out a secure area for the
children to be and that's it would
obviously be a secure place that we
would we would make it secure for the
children most of it I think it's already
in the report that I got because I sent
my business plan across to the case
officer any questions okay so done okay
sorry give you two very well just to
clarify them there will be a secure area
it's just the plans were not detailed
enough to alleviate the fears the Town
Council because their main concern is it
appears to be security and you're saying
there will be a secure area it's just
isn't clear for the plans yet yes okay
thank you mr. Perry I think councillor
Donna's stolen my my thunder really but
would I be right in thinking obviously
before you can actually operate a
business as a children's
area it has to all be inspected to
conform to austere regulations which is
what I am but it's nice to hear that
that's confirmed by yourself absolutely
thank you I've got one slight question
hence the Barker has supported
applications and there's a demonstrable
need for a local you know supervision
it's been a couple letters of support as
well I know you mention the business
plan and what when we started we did
look at how many applications have been
approved and we knew there was 426
houses that were due to be built in ship
stone and we also know the nursery that
in ships and is at its max and there are
waiting lists as I've said my mum's a
child minder and she has regular calls
asking if she has spaces which she
doesn't she is full and we do attend
toddler groups where we've asked parents
that we'll be going back to work what
their plans are and their thoughts so we
have tried to cover a few bases of why
it's a need in ships 10 thank you agreed
yes mr. fielding I think well I think
it's not an appropriate question at the
moment
it's not a revenant planning one I can
understand where it's coming from but I
think yes you could say there might be a
wee condition
sorry I dunno any further questions for
the applicant thank you mister sighs
you're free to go thank you right now
okay I haven't got the board member so I
won't forget counts the barky like I did
ten slow tunnel
so go on two points of clarification it
didn't have to have planning permission
for the fence because he wasn't a meter
high
it says when he gets the two meters
that's their plan is that correct the
fence Horace thank you correct means of
enclosure fact up to two meters high
were you not fronting a highway can be
undertaken under permitted development
in this case because obviously there are
concerns regarding the lack of
information relating to the outdoor play
space should you wish to move to
recommendation then we would recommend
an additional condition requiring
submission of the details location size
of the play area and its means of
enclosure just so that we can be honest
you can be absolutely certain that
that's been achieved me to propose that
in the conditions if it was approved
Genesis advising his difference between
telling and revising because we can't
tell you anything counsel Vance though
we'll try and advise you right any other
further points of clarification
okay so Bryan no right we happy can stop
our very happy to second
I think whilst it's it's unfortunate
that the ward members not here she is
clearly supported this application which
reflects the need particularly with the
increasing households it's it looks a
very good location and there's no
objection from highways so I would be
totally in support and I think we also
have to remember we are trying to
support new businesses in the area as
well so it gets thumbs up all round for
me so I'm delighted to second it can
slip ons very fully supportive of this
family business I'm sure that they will
put a fence up because I said my school
got at the nursery and I don't know
exactly what's going to happen but there
was a great lot of civil servants and
people coming around with paperwork and
talking about this and talking about
that so if they're not secure they'll
get slows down and I should be voting
for the recommendation and good luck
thank you very much the only thing I
would add this I think it was sensible
of
the ship's own Onstad to come and raise
their concerns because it has generated
an extra condition just to make sure
being with such a sensitive subject so
they've exercised their democratic right
and it's generated an extra condition so
I think that's that sense of also I
think we should know about it so all
those in favor with the condition of
course that we were advised by the
Planning Manager not told thank you
so this committee resolves to grant
application 18 / 0 0 4 to 5 ful just go
on the next item of the agenda which is
the start time of meeting so two we're
just like the views of the members cash
the Perry I've got real problems trying
to get here for six six o'clock whilst I
work in Clinton because of the traffic
coming in and out of Stratford it takes
me 40 minutes to get here from Kyneton
even if I leave at 5:30 so if if it's
moved back to six o'clock then I might
as well turn up for the second
application because I will not be able
to vote on the first application it took
me an hour to get it for a problem this
afternoon he needed Eastern relief
I would struggle to get here for six
o'clock given different work commitments
and I come from I very rarely come from
just as local as Clinton so six fifteen
is just about doable youngster I think
um I'm very in toward 615 as well from
personal reasons so yeah so I'm happy to
provide that we stay at six fifteen
seconds O'Donnell all those in favor any
against any other section yeah so we
will continue continue it right right
come up yes right we move on to item
number seven business right thank you
very much I will now close this meeting
at 7:22 thank you